el desfile anual del día de la victoria
en rusia que se celebra en mayo es una
demostración de fuerza y de disciplina
pero desde el principio de la invasión a
ucrania empezaron a aparecer grietas
mostrando otra imagen del ejército ruso
la de la desorganización y los errores
de los soldados inexpertos cameros el
ejército ruso está formado por oficiales
y soldados no lograron crear un cuerpo
de oficiales subalternos que es un
cuerpo intermedio que tenemos en los
ejércitos occidentales cuando un
ejército carece de liderazgo los
soldados son abandonados a su suerte que
no hay manera de contenerlos y comandar
los de cerca para evitar errores y
atrocidades de voldemort es decir
lección' para suplir la falta de
liderazgo sobre el terreno algunos
generales rusos fueron llamados para ir
al frente un hecho extraño
otra cosa que la invasión ucraniana ha
puesto en el punto de mira es el origen
socioeconómico de los que se alistan en
el ejército ruso entre los soldados
rusos que han muerto en ucrania muchos
de ellos jóvenes e inexpertos ninguno es
de moscú
la gran mayoría procede de las regiones
más pobres donde alistarse en el
ejército es una oportunidad para
ascender en la escala social en
daguestán una de las regiones más pobres
el desempleo ronda el 15% tres veces más
que en el resto del país el salario
medio es de unos trescientos cincuenta
euros es decir unos cien euros menos de
lo que gana un soldado y
hay mucha gente que intenta alistarse
muchos jóvenes para los que el ejército
es la única salida en un entorno
económico muy cerrado todos estos
jóvenes son vistos como carne de cañón
el hecho de que mueran su salud su vida
el estado en el que volverán a casa del
ejército es la menor de las
preocupaciones del ejército
para compensar la inexperiencia de las
tropas el ejército ruso ha reclutado
mercenarios que han acumulado
experiencia luchando en guerras ajenas